last time on the OIC Diaries I am down a total
of 21 lbs after three doses which is awesome I'm
getting a little bit obsessive over it not really
obsessive over what I'm doing but obsessive over
what can I do to speed up the process so I don't
know if there's like a correlation between OIC
and the rise of anxiety or or depression or those
sort of manic behaviors uh and the mental health
issue so I just like to see results right away
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen in today's video we'll be catching up with
my friend business partner and manager ginger on
her OIC weight loss Journey now last month on my
channel I reviewed a handful of OIC what aena day
videos that have basically just been circulating
around online and I gave my honest yet educated
dietitian thoughts and this week ginger has asked
me to do the same for her now a quick disclaimer
that this video will include numbers calories
and Extreme Weight Loss discussion also please
note that the individual in the series is not my
actual client so any suggestions are for general
knowledge and education only everyone's needs are
unique and really should be discussed oneon-one
with your healthcare provider now before we
get into it let's bring in Jinder and we can
catch up on some of her impressive results
and Journey so far but let's talk about my
New Year's resolutions with my sponsor hungry
root so I am all about setting smart goals so
instead of lofty vague resolutions like lose 10 lb
I'm all about actionable steps that you can take
like having one meatless meal a day or trying one
new recipe every week or switching up your weekly
fruits and veg and services like hungry root can
actually make it doable hungry root is an online
grocery service that makes makes eating healthier
easy and more accessible you can fill out a quick
quiz and hungry will recommend fresh groceries
and simple 10-minute recipes tailor to your goals
preferences and abilities you can edit your weekly
deliveries to choose exactly what you want or you
can let hungry root take the guest workk out of it
for you they can tailor your order for gluten-free
vegan vegetarian and dairyfree and they offer over
2,000 recipes so you will never get bored honestly
it's been a great way to get out of the postol
cooking red and to save money time food waste
and multiple trips to the grocery store I love all
their different prepped veggie stir fry mixes and
the kids love their little snack packs they are
definitely making lunch packing stressfree so
if you want to try out hungry root yourself the
first 100 people to use my code Abby 40 will get
40% off of their first order so use the link in
the description or scan the QR code and use Abby
40 for 40% off welcome Ginger so nice to see you
hi ABY good morning everyone um let's do a quick
little recap here with some rapid fire questions
number one how many weeks now have you been on
OIC 33 weeks wow 33 weeks seems like a pregnancy
that's like I'm 33 weeks along yeah I know love
that except instead of gaining weight I'm losing
weight right right right exactly um what dose
are you on right now 2 milligram excellent um how
much weight have you lost so far the big question
yeah so I have lost 34 and2 lbs wow how are you
feeling about this that's huge I feel really good
it's funny I was shopping yesterday and you know
instead of shopping for extra large I was shopping
for medium so like that was a big I mean listen
the numbers on clothes as we know are just like
fictional um but it was very surreal to me to
actually like be trying on medium so that was I
haven't I haven't been there in such a long time
so that was was a nice it was a nice feeling it
just like it's kind of like oh you see your body
every day in the mirror but the clothes these new
clothes are just seeing your new body now right
so right oh and so tell me I mean I have to do the
math math is not my thing but how many typically
how much are you losing per week just about a
pound amazing and that's exactly really where
we want to be because one of the big risks when
it comes to drugs like OIC is muscle loss because
of rapid weight loss so we really want to stay in
that sweet spot of 1 to 2 pounds per week to help
to reduce that risk so that is a great weight loss
rate we love that okay so any major side effects
that we're dealing with right now yeah so this
new one that I'm dealing with is hair loss and I'm
not sure if it's related to like loss of nutrients
or the OIC or just like it's a very stressful time
and like we've got a lot going on and just like in
work in general in my life so um my doctor says
it's stress related but if it doesn't stop then
we have to pursue something else but got coming
out in clumps like while I'm in the shower it's
not fun I'm so sorry to hear that I find like hair
loss is so traumatic any I'm also going through a
little bit of hair loss because my ADHD meds and
it's it's it's really tough I'm sure on on men
too but like especially for us women for whom like
you know our hair means a lot to us um so that's
really that's that sucks um yeah and I don't have
a lot of hair to begin with so oh yeah I mean St
with me my hair is very fine so like to lose any
I'm like no I I let that grow now just for anyone
who is watching or taking OIC or considering
taking OIC hair loss isn't considered a common
side effect but it does seem to happen around 5%
of patients using glp1 agonists and experts think
that the hair loss is related to something called
telen effu VM uh they don't actually think it's
the medication itself but rather the hormonal
changes and the metabolic stress on the body
that usually is coming from rapid weight loss
so usually this starts about a few months into
treatment and can usually reverse over six to 12
months once your weight loss has stabilized but
this is really why nutrition is so important so
you know maybe taking a multivitamin would be a
good idea here plus of course focusing on protein
throughout the day seeing as our hair is built
on protein so that's something to think about
really for anyone on OIC duh duh we know yeah
exactly I have no idea but speaking of protein and
vitamins you made me look at some of your wet ien
a day videos so I feel like we're gonna just wash
them together and I'm going to give you my honest
thoughts are you ready Ginger let's do it let's do
it so I start my day with a cup of espresso coffee
as we can see here followed by a single egg with
some salt and pepper and I finished this off with
um some toast some Earth Balance and a piece
of guda cheese and wow this was delicious all
pre 8:30 for lunch I had a beef B gigy with some
carrots kimchi and rice I have that so that was
my portion then I had a piece of chocolate about
this size two pieces actually and a chicken vit
a bowl for dinner okay Ginger everything there
looked so delicious that chocolate bar I don't
know what that is but I want it um and based
on my rough calculations I counted about 1100
calories um which you know for most people might
be a pretty aggressive calorie deficit and I'm not
sure what your BMR is because again I'm not your
dietitian but if you are losing your weight at
a reasonable pace of a pound a week this might be
the right amount of calories for you at this time
that said not enough protein Ginger not enough
protein we need to get that protein up I think
I counted like 50 gr of protein in the day which
is about 20% of your total calories coming from
protein and I went to a lot more detail in this
on my video for macro ranges but we need a ton of
protein when we're in a calorie deficit basically
the greater the calorie defs it the more protein
we need and this is basically just help prevent
muscle wasting which is one of the main major
concerns when it comes to glp1 agonists like OIC
so we generally recommend like 1.8 g of protein
per kilogram of body weight or around 30% of your
total calorie should be coming from protein but
you're only eating like roughly 1,000 calories so
1.8 gr per kilogram would be very difficult unless
you're just just eating protein um but even if we
work off of the 30% goal that would be around 85
G so almost double what you're consuming currently
and I really think that that breakfast meal would
be the best meal to try to bump this up right
um one egg has only like s g of protein and we
ideally want to get that up to like 20 to 30 G per
meal so that could mean doing one whole egg plus a
few egg whites in there um a protein shake Greek
yogurt cottage cheese would be a really great way
to start the day those would be some of my kind
of more high uh protein options for breakfast also
Ginger where's the fruit and vegetables in the
meals yes girl barely not much not much right so
obviously it's not realistic to get your full five
10 servings of fruits and vegetables on a very low
calorie diet like this but I counted maybe a/4
cup of carrots and a few kernels of corn um and
then the rest of your carbs are basically coming
from lower fiber options like white bread uh white
white rice and then of course chocolate which
we love of course we have to make space for the
chocolate um but the recommendation when it comes
to fiber is about 28 gr for women you're getting
five so I only counted five gram of fiber in this
day and again I think it's really hard to get a
full 30 G of fiber when you're only consuming 1,00
calories but we could do some super super simple
swaps here just to bump that up a little bit so
you know instead of the white rice or or you know
whatever your your typical grains are we could
do higher fiber green like a chickpea pasta or
quinoa which would actually double as protein and
the fiber so it does a little double duty there to
bump that up as well um and I always tell people
don't count calories count colors so I want you
to think about trying to get in three different
colors in your day this is a really great tip
for anybody watching so three colors could mean
berries at breakfast you could do some greens
with your lunch and like bell peppers at dinner
time and that way you're going to get a variety
of different fiber sources plus more antioxidants
and if it still is very difficult for you to meet
your fiber needs I maybe would consider you know
adding a Prebiotic fiber supplement in there and
taking it close to bed so that it doesn't affect
your hunger uh levels throughout the day you don't
want it to like further affect your appetite and
you not want to get enough calories in or enough
protein in so that's when I would do it right
before bed so what would happen if I took it
earlier in the day you you can but you just have
to monitor your appetite because you know fiber
makes you feel full and I wouldn't want to be
compromising on you know antioxidant rich foods
or protein rich foods because you're just feeling
full because you're on OIC and you're now taking
a fiber supplement you're feeling extra full and
therefore you may not be able to get the actual
bare nutrients that you need to thrive right
we were talking about the hair loss we we still
need nutrients I see I didn't I didn't know any
yeah yeah the things I'm learning out thanks for
learning okay let's learn some more we're going
to watch another one of your your wedding a days
started the day with my espresso coffee then I had
a protein shake then I had a pork Teriyaki Bowl
which I haveed and added some soy sauce which was
delicious then my stello two pieces of licorice
okay who making I actually had four then I had
some snap peas and hummus and finish the day off
with some pasta and sausage and this piece of
delicious chocolate yum okay so the calories on
this day were slightly lower which I don't love
about 1 th000 calories uh cuz again we don't want
to risk muscle mass loss but the nutrients and
macros we actually did a lot better on so almost
hit that 30% of calories from protein Mark uh you
ate 70 gr protein as opposed to like 50 in the
other day and there was 12 G of fiber this time
so definitely huge progress here I really think
that having that protein shake in the morning was
you're saving greas because at least then you're
getting a full serving of protein right in right
first thing in the morning right did it with the
snap piece for a little more fiber uh that was
a really great snack just to sneak in some extra
More Produce and get a little bit of some color in
there um but again I probably would try to swap in
higher fiber grains or chickpea pasta as opposed
to Rice I might put some fiber rich berries or
greens in the protein smoothie at breakfast um and
if you're feeling snacky I love me licorice but
maybe do like half Licorice and half turkey jerky
or do a bowl of cottage cheese with some of the
chocolate shredded on top cuz that way you still
get the protein in those snacks you know what yeah
like you guys you know I'm all about adding not
restricting add don't restrict and I want to make
sure you still have your fun Foods in the day but
ultimately when your appetite is so limited your
your caloric intake is so limited you still have
to make a bit more of an effort to meet your basic
nutrient needs so yeah the protein does need
to be number one okay noted so in terms of the
turkey jerky like if I were to incorporate that
or like a pepperette yeah like I always assumed
those were just like super high in fat so and they
probably it depends on the brand it depends on the
brand yeah um so definitely compare packages um
the states have a lot more options but you know
compare packages look for a low lower sodium look
for a lower um uh fat options especially like a a
turkey over a pork or a beef um there are now
a lot more uh nutritious jerky based products
yeah I love that stuff I know I know it's a good
it's a good way to switch it up if you want like
a little salty with a little sweet okay so big
picture here folks big picture Ginger I want you
to focus on protein at every meal and snack and
to get in some fruits and vegetables so if you
can just focus on those two things I really think
that the rest will work itself out which is really
the perk of OIC so how do we feel about that
love it love it I love these little tips these
little tips are great amazing amazing yeah I also
want to talk about the holidays here because I
keep seeing headlines being like it's OIC ruining
Christmas because people are used to the holiday
being this like binge Fest for everyone this like
Collective binge and some people are just worried
that it feels less festive when you don't Gorge
yourself so I'm I'm just curious like you know
having gone through the holidays now did anyone
give you a hard time for not eating as much as you
used to or as what everybody else is eating like
how did that go gosh no number one I'm so open
about this so you know if somebody has a problem
they're not telling me to my face but okay it's
not really it's not not a me problem it's a you
problem if it's a problem for you at all so you
know what I mean oh for sure no listen I'm still
enjoying everything that I want to eat the only
things that I'm really having a hard time with
that I have to be like really mindful is any of
those fried foods they just don't sit well in my
stomach but I'm having the turkey I'm having the
stuffing I'm having a little bit of the gravy I'm
having the mashed potatoes I'm having the pumpkin
pie like I'm I'm doing it all I'm just not doing a
huge portion Y and if I feel full and I'm starting
to feel full I'm walking away I I love that and
that's that's the way it should be right like you
are just listening to your body and and you've now
realized that some of these like very very fatty
foods perhaps don't sit as well so like turkey
would be a better option than like a very very
well marbled prime rib for example and so you make
those choices accordingly and what feels good to
your body and and that's kind of one of the big
perks of oen piic is basically relearning your
body's cues and needs so I think that's really
really great um but I have another question about
the holidays because one of the the big side
effects that we hear from a lot of OIC users
is that they generally don't feel like drinking as
much or at all um what's been your experience with
alcohol and OIC I used to love winding down with
a glass of wine sitting by the fireplace you know
maybe watching a television show or actually
let's be honest I watch the news like 247 but
depressing it's not really been wind down material
lately so um so no so but I just haven't had that
craving I I find like I'm having a glass of water
instead um but if I'm with my family or my friends
I'm definitely having a cocktail than a glass of
wine or two um so I I'm not not drinking but I'm
only drinking in social situations like I'm not
having anything on my own and I'm popped out at
two really yep I think that's excellent I mean
we've we've talked on my channel most recently
about um alcohol and the effect on weight loss
and weight gain and I think that yeah that that
two drink Mark is is really great place to to be
in to stop so I'm glad that that's feeling more
intuitive for you you as well so that's fantastic
um but we mentioned earlier OIC shortages yeah so
like Novo nordis who is the maker of OIC have been
warning that they are expecting that there's going
to be these worldwide shortages that are going to
be continuing into the first quarter of 2024 and
then after that well who really knows what's
going to happen so what is your plan so when
they increased my dose to the 2 milligrams that's
when they were starting to talk about the shortage
coming to Canada originally we were actually
in a good place uh the US had major shortages
but Canada was going to be fine um and it was I
think October shortage and I had to call around
different pharmacies to try and see who had it
because I hadn't really spoken to my doctor yet
about when the shortage happens what do I do um
so I found a pharmacy and then they then they had
the shortage so my doctor and I um talked about
different solutions so saxenda was a solution but
that's lorag glutide I had previously tried seenda
in my younger years um it's a daily injection um
it just didn't work for me I think it was the
daily in injection like I just mentally couldn't
do it and hadn't gone through the egg freezing at
that point so didn't know what it was like to give
myself three or four needles a day yeah uh now I'm
fine one a week is nothing um so but what we ended
up where we landed was rebellis so rebellis is
the oral it's the same drug so it's smuti um but
it's a daily pill you have to fast for a little
bit after taking it in order for your body to
absorb it so it's kind of like just wrapping my
head around um how that was going to work okay
my doctor prescribed that sent it to my Pharmacy
and my pharmacist actually called me and in the
craziest shocker they had 1 milligram pens so they
called me and they were like let's keep you on OIC
because we've got them in stock however my dad
had just told me that he couldn't get the OIC my
dad is diabetic has had a heart attack and is on
OIC for diabetes smaller dose than what I'm on now
cuz I'm on the kind of the therapeutic weight
loss dose so I I'm like can instead of me can
my dad can I get it for my dad she's like yep we
have some in stock like no problem so we actually
transferred his prescription over um to get the 1
milligram yeah so so you really it's about calling
around in Canada and some are getting the 0.
five some are getting the one it makes zero
sense it is not practical um but rebellis seems
to be a good option um and there's no shortage
of ralis so oh well that's great yeah it is an
oral medication no needles at least for those
who are freaked out about needles it's slightly
less effective than OIC especially because the
max dose is equivalent to basically like half of
what you're used to taking it's equivalent to 1
milligram of ozempic but who knows you know if if
you end up going that route and and you need to
stay on that for a while it might even be kind of
better for you it's it's it's something that you
can you can test out and see and then hopefully uh
you can get back to whatever method works best for
you shortly after once they figure the demand is
clearly not going away and so yeah they'll just
have to ramp up production I guess so yeah it's
definitely not going away now that Oprah came out
and fully admitted that she's taking a weight loss
drug as well which you know I was kind of like yes
Oprah like I was like finally you know um because
you know what she said in that interview was this
is the tool that I needed to stop yo-yo diving
and that's how I felt my whole life like I've
just been up and down and up and down and up and
down and it has never been healthy right and it
has never been fun and um I just you know what if
that's if this is the drug that some people who
don't have that hunger Q need in order to avoid
diabetes and heart issues and the other things
that our medical system you know gets pressured
and you know that that's put on the medical system
and this helps curb that y Bring It On yeah and
you know again this is part of the reason why
we're doing this series is we want to uh remove
the stigma away from folks who are just getting
the health care that they need um you know no
different than getting chemo for cancer um or you
know get taking steroids for um IB IBD you know
or mental health medication like we like you know
I do um we really want to help folks feel like
they don't need to have any more shame or feel
any more judged than they already have in their
life for just being you know in a larger body
so I think this is great and of course somebody
like Oprah is got such clout such presence so um
you know I I hope her her her giving her blessing
is enough to help encourage others to to you know
no longer be judging those who are seeing this
as the easy way out as we've said if I may on
easy way out it's not easy no because you know you
have to learn how to consume properly or else you
will not feel good and I'm also I mean I'm doing
a pretty active effort at the fitness portion of
it too like trying to balance it with Fitness
but it is not easy and what what I hope doesn't
happen with Oprah coming out because Oprah does
have an investment in Weight Watchers which we
need and which we don't Weight Weight Watchers
was was just a mind to me anyways but you and
many others yes you know but but Weight Watcher
has invested in the company that now prescribes
weight loss medication so obviously it's her her
best interest to promote it and to talk about it
from a financial perspective but I also believe
that in the long run if this this could if this is
a life-changing drug it will help like it'll just
be super impactful for everyone M exactly y so
I'm super excited to check in with you again and
maybe another month or so um and I hope that you
know I hope that the new drug works out for you
and we can kind of continue on this journey and
you're feeling good about it no new side effects
H you know I know that anytime you switch a drug
it can be a little bit um of a challenge there
might be some hiccups along the way along the way
but hopefully it's a smooth transition and we can
check in with you in a few months everybody please
leave us some really nice supportive comments
uh down below we all know that sharing these
stories are not easy especially in this world
where there is so much judgment for any choice
a woman makes for her own body so let's try to
keep it supportive and kind here in the comments
and thank you Ginger again for for sharing your
story thanks Abby awesome and don't forget to
hit that subscribe button if you are not already
and I will see you next time on aby's kitchen bye
a